die weltwoche auf der anklagebank bei
den zürcher prozessen herzlich
willkommen bei kulturplatz extra ich bin
hier vor dem zürcher theater neumarkt
und gespannt ob wir in den nächsten drei
tagen tatsächlich theatergeschichte
geschrieben wird in einem einmaligen
experiment soll sich eine reale
wochenzeitung in einem prozess auf der
theaterbühne verteidigen
die wirklichkeit soll also drei tage
lang vor einem inszenierten gericht
verhandelt werden und der ausgang dieser
geschichte der ist noch komplett offen
die weltwoche steht vor gericht
wenn auch nur im theater angeklagt gegen
drei artikeln des schweizerischen
strafgesetzbuches verstoßen zu haben
gegen das verbot die bevölkerung zu
schrecken
gegen das verbot der
rassendiskriminierung gegen das verbot
die verfassungsmäßige ordnung zu stören
in ihren artikeln soll die weltwoche
gegen minderheiten gehetzt und panik
verbreitet und verfassungsorgane
diskriminiert haben weltwoche chef roger
köppel sieht das anders
laut bruch ist ganz klar hat ganz klar
das publizistische prinzip einer sitz in
der nacht die meinungsvielfalt wo das
nötig ich herstelle durch gegenläufige
position und zweitens durch recherche
reale missstände aufzudecken
das ist es auch verständlich dass eine
woche wo auch am nerv und zum teil und
es vorzieht recherchiert sich bei mir
zumindest oder im bundes unter dem nervt
sie dass sie widerstand auslöst denen
man sich erstellt die idee zum zur
prozess stammt von regisseur milo rau
für ihn geht es nicht allein um die
weltwoche
er will eine breite diskussion über
meinungsbildung in einer demokratie
meinungsfreiheit oder gesellschaftliche
verantwortung
das ist hier die frage ich glaube das
war stetig wo auf dem wert 1 2 durch das
macht dich das gesellschaftliche
verantwortung und die presse frei zuber
bringt also dass ich das zivilisierte
umgang mit den angriff nehmen
ich denke dass das widerspruch sind
sondern ihr wunschziel also das war eine
direkte wattierte ist wichtiger als das
urteil am schluss in 14 stunden konnte
die bühne wo sich in aussage machen sie
wenn glück tiefgründig befragt und er
wird zum schluss ich sagte pendelt er zu
schuldig oder unschuldig ausfall das ist
gesellschaft die verantwortung wichtiger
recherche journalismus wichtiger
erst in der schlussphase abhängig vor
die geschworenen ist nicht wichtig
punkten das was vorher passieren
sie selbst bezeichnet sich als links
beklagt aber in gewissen arroganz der
eigene reise und anti reflex cargo mit
waldwoche sieger der wahl durch die
plattform spielt sich sinnlos und
reflexe wie man einfach aufs podium
stellt nicht darüber regt und so weiter
tabuisiert
es scheint so dass verschwindet ich
denke muss darüber reden will sich mit
dem auseinandersetzen dass ich denke
sehr wichtig
das theater ist auch ein ziemlich
geschlossene rahmen also was löst sie da
es außerhalb vor dem theater gedanken
ich habe viele themen ich gemacht und
denkt so was als auslöser sind aber oft
noch voll gefragt kann ich hoffe man
dass man zum beispiel einfach sein muss
darüber reden sich mit tabuisiert
natürliches theater inneren konflikt
symbole schuss gehandelt werden mit
wenig blüht eine symbolische
öffentlichkeit hergestellt wird
die demokratische öffentlichkeit die
große fähigkeit von ganze land muss
natürlich immer wieder auf einen punkt
vom gesamte volk quasi hergestellt
das kann man nicht viel sagen danke
ich stehe hier mitten in bühnenbild für
diesen fiktiven prozess es werden also
keine schauspieler teilnehmen sondern
reale akteure dazu gehören auch die
geschworenen die schließlich das urteil
fällen werden sie wurden extra gecastet
aus der bevölkerung um einen querschnitt
der schweizerischen bevölkerung zu
verkörpern
ja und hier hinter mir werden dann die
hauptakteure platz nehmen
auf diesem stuhl hier wird verlegerin
anrufer platz nehmen die den prozess
moderiert sie wird unterstützt von alt
bundesrichter josep bei der die funktion
des rechtsexperten übernimmt der prozess
ist anstoß für orte dialog führen gute
meinungsaustausch über die doch recht
verschiedene umfasse erhöhte durch
politik und über gesellschaftliche thema
ins spiel rein gesetzt den es jetzt
beide parteien verpflichtet und wir
hoffen dass innerhalb vor dem spiel hat
es möglich wird themen die über der
aktuelle fall der verhandelt wird
hinausgehen und in der gesellschaft
dafür sorge dass man sich wieder fragt
wahrscheinlich relevanten hier setzt die
anklage der auf migrationsrecht
spezialisierte jurist marc spescha hat
auch die anklageschrift verfasst und an
seiner seite
der österreichische journalist robert
misik über 80 prozent für meine klienten
können zu deiner zielgruppe weltwoche
wiederholt und immer bietet infocus
nimmt verächtlich macht und verunglimpft
von der thematik her ist es natürlich
eine große geschichte dass man diesen
rechtspopulismus und journalismus quasi
gleich strategien zum teil haben diese
überbietung und zuspitzung strategien
sich einmal gewissermaßen verknüpft von
diesem tisch aus wird die weltwoche
verteidigt und zwar von milieu anwalt
valentin landmann
svp kantonsrat claudio zanetti das hätte
gewaltige dynamik des interessantes
thema es geht um neue tabus doch mal
ganz die themenbereiche klammer dass man
gerne und mit roboter auf 6 oder sollen
wir dort frei sich eine äußere mich
interessiert vor allem wie die das
interessant finden will ich meine liebe
medienfreiheit red - wochen sieht es
sich medien reflexartig auf sie die
freiheit stelle und das macht es im fall
von der waldwoche nöten das finde ich
eine gewisse schizophrenie befehle
medien dass man einfach das buch liefert
die post
dem auftakt vor allem neugierde zu
spüren wir von saf kultur werden alle
drei prozesstage beobachten und auch
zusammenfassend berichten
prozesstag 1 vorhang auf für die
eröffnungssitzung eine neue form der
auseinandersetzung beginn der zürcher
prozesse zuerst der blick in die
vergangenheit programm speck über die
geschichte der weltwoche
nicht immer war die weltwoche im besitz
dessen denn die öffentlichkeit für deren
inhaber wild wechselvolle politische
ausrichtung oft abenteuerliche
besitzverhältnisse dass der titel
weltwoche das alles durchgestanden und
überlebt hat grenzt an ein medien wonach
die zweite eröffnungsrede hält kurt
imhof im auftreten sie begrenzt sagen
stand der kürze halber werte sieht er
widme ich mich hier dem faktum dass auf
der weltwoche draufsteht was nicht drin
ist die neue welt woche behauptet sie
betreibe eine kontinuierlich
kontinuierliche berichterstattung als
liberal erwarte dass hohes gericht ist
ein dreister etiketten schwingt inmitten
unserer fetischen republik haben wir ein
organ das ehrbare sie teuer es
diffamiert minderheiten diskriminiert
und unsere nationalen wie
internationalen institutionen der
freiheit diskreditiert die geschworenen
werden vorgestellt
ein hoffentlich repräsentativer
querschnitt der bevölkerung die es zu
überzeugen gilt geschworener nummer drei
bitte nehmen sie ihren namen
ich heiße vertreter für welchen beruf
üben sie zurzeit aus ich bin
rentnerin ich arbeite als sitz nach
woche im spital und als freie
mitarbeiter für den regionalteil einer
zeitung geschorene nummer sechs welchen
beruf üben sie zurzeit aus ich bin
zurzeit maturandin an der kreis
stadelhofen haben sie nähere beziehung
zu einer der parteien
nein sind sie bereit nach bestem wissen
und gewissen über die hier vorgelegten
fragen ohne ansehen von person herkunft
und politische ausrichtung zu
entscheiden ja möchten sie noch etwas
anfügen nein die anklage beginnt mit
ihrem plädoyer
sehr geehrte frau vorsitzende
geschätztes präsidium wehrte geschworene
die situation ist paradox
mein kollege musik und die ich vertreten
hier im namen der aufgeklärten
öffentlichkeit die anklage gegen eine
bestimmte spielart der medienfreiheit
obwohl wir mit schreib- und rhede
verboten nichts am hut haben lügen
bleiben auch dann lügen wenn sie unter
dem deckmantel der meinungsfreiheit
daherkommen am pranger dieses
journalismus stehen der islam die
ausländer die kopftuchträgerin der
ausländische sozialhilfebezüger
muslimische sozialbetrüger insbesondere
roma und schließlich auch eine
unabhängige justiz namentlich das
bundesgericht die zürcher prozesse
sollen diese entwicklung mit ihrer hilfe
einhalt gebieten
eine erste antwort von seiten der
verteidigung
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
es geht um ganz fundamentaler rechte
die weltwoche ist ein relativ kleines
medium aber es ist enorm wichtig dass
wir diese pluralität der meinungen haben
dass man eben sagen darf was nicht
mainstream ist dass man sagen darf was
anderen nicht passt dass man mitunter
vielleicht sogar etwas krass formulieren
darf natürlich jedes freiheitsrecht hat
seine grenzen
bei freiheitsrechten wie der
pressefreiheit müssen wir sorge tragen
dass sorge tragen ist auch eine
gesellschaftliche verantwortung von uns
allen
damit möchte ich meinem co verteidiger
herrn zanetti übergeben präsidentin
höchstgericht daumenregel sich kleid
wurde war doch so genannte liberale
propaganda und was heißt so liberal
liberalen seit jedenfalls ihren libero
freiheit ich muss mir sie und frank gott
und ich bin überzeugt dass sie wüssten
dass man zum freiheit ganz zart
pflanzliche möglichst wenig zeit in der
lunge hat chile und der freiheit geht
immer um freiheit von andersdenkenden
hiermit ist die heutige verhandlung
geschlossen
ja das war erste auftakt sowohl vom
prozess wie auch von unserer
berichterstattung der erste prozesstag
war geprägt von rhetorik morgen geht es
um argumente
ja und wenn sie zu hause auch direkter
dabei sein wollen dann empfehle ich den
blick durch unsere webcam auf unserer
website sf punkt sehr schrecklich kultur
finden sie auch diverse artikel
zuschauerreaktionen und auch die bilder
unserer gerichtszeichner hiervon
kulturplatz extra wir melden uns
übermorgen sonntag wieder und zwar um 23
uhr 25 mit einem ausführlichen speziell
auch sf 1 ja ich bin gespannt wohin
dieses experiment führen wird ich hoffe
ihm geht es genauso in diesem sinne bis
dann